j'ouvre notre second débat du bas de
société vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour je vous
propose un gros plan sur l'exclusion
numérique ce chiffre 13 millions de
personnes sont en situation
d'électronisme de notre pays des
mini-faces aux ordinateurs et Internet
ils ont évidemment difficilement accès
au service public pour les aider il y a
par exemple les bus France service comme
celui-ci qui sillonne les routes autour
de Coutances en étant Normandie
reportage du GO Lemonnier je veux créer
une boîte mail la poste c'est une boîte
qui est assez facile d'accès c'est
devenu l'étape incontournable avant
toute démarche administrative la
création d'une adresse mail
et je fais ça donc votre adresse a bien
été
frustré Sylvie vient refaire son permis
de conduire l'occasion d'apprendre les
bases du numérique pour devenir un jour
autonome sur internet ça c'est agence
nationale des titres sécurisés NTS et
c'est bien une adresse point gouv vous
êtes sûr que c'est l'adresse de l'État
etc une autre adresse
ou des fois on pourrait vous demander de
l'argent dans ce département rural
déserté par les services publics la
communauté de communes de Coutances dans
la Manche à imaginer ce concept le bus
prend service un guichet itinérant qui
fait le tour des 46 communes de la
collectivité le dispositif a été lancé
l'an dernier pour maintenir le contact
humain
sont déjà rassurés parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont pouvoir que c'est sûr ils
vont être recontacté
et avoir une réponse car plus que la
fracture numérique c'est un immense
faussé entre les citoyens et
l'administration compta combler ces deux
agentes du bus français
l'administratif donc c'est des gens qui
même quand c'était en version papier
était déjà un petit peu perdu et avec
l'informatique et le numérique en plus
ouais on est confronté à des gens qui
sont qui sont complètement à côté de la
plaque bonjour Nadine voit enfin le bout
du tunnel cette ATSEM commence tout
juste à percevoir sa complémentaire
retraite un dossier qu'a entièrement
constitué l'équipe de France service je
ne sais déjà parler sur un ordinateur on
a ouvert j'ai jamais appris déjà et je
suis pas y aller donc j'aurais été
incapable de le faire moi-même c'était
même pas même pas un visage et par
téléphone je comprends pas plus que ça
quoi j'ai un peu de mal par téléphone
j'aime bien voir les gens ou comme ça et
dire voilà moi mon problème il est là je
ne comprends pas ça tout de suite et
puis j'espère qu'on se revoit pas
moi un contact retrouvé avec les usagers
mais insuffisant selon les services de
la Défenseur des droits ce qu'on observe
c'est que certes ça répond à un besoin
mais qu'on est à la fois encore loin de
la cible sur le nombre de personnes qui
ont besoin d'être accompagnés pour
accéder au service public et puis que ça
ne remplace pas complètement non plus la
réalité de l'interaction que vous avez
avec un service public lorsque vous êtes
à un guichet vous avez une question sur
le droit que vous avez à la retraite aux
prestations de Pôle emploi à la sécurité
sociale où vous pouvez avoir besoin
d'échanger avec un technicien qui
connaît vos droits qui va pouvoir
intervenir sur votre dossier bref ce que
vous faisiez auparavant à un guichet
malgré les efforts pour résorber la
fracture numérique grâce au guichet
France services 80% des réclamations
adressées à la Défenseur des droits on
concernait les services publics en 2021
les 5e assises de la cohésion numérique
et territoriale s'ouvre deux mains dans
notre débat on va se demander comment
lutter donc contre l'exclusion numérique
avec mes invités Martin filleul bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
du Nord ou de la commission supérieure
du numérique et des post membres du
Conseil National du Numérique Muriel
Bardet bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes directrice de l'engagement
sociétal au groupe La Poste Joël
Tolédano bonsoir professeur émérite
d'économie associé à la chair
gouvernance et régulations de
l'Université Paris Dauphine et vous
publiez ce livre Gafa reprenons le
pouvoir aux éditions Odile Jacob on est
également en duplex en visioconférence
avec Jean-Marc et snoke et directeur
général de The Land et auteurs de ce
livre bienvenue dans la nouvelle
ruralité publiée aux éditions
l'harmattant bonsoir à vous Mathieu est
évidemment restez à mes côtés je
voudrais d'abord reprendre ce chiffre
moi je vous avoue qu'il m'a vraiment
frappé je ne m'attendais pas à ça 13
millions de Français en situation
électronise ça veut dire que ils sont
perdus face Internet à un ordinateur un
accès numérique Martin ça veut dire que
ça ne concerne pas seulement les plus
âgés d'entre nous déjà il faut être
clair sur qui sont les 13 millions et
loin de là puisqu'on dit qu'il y a un
Français sur deux en réalité qui n'est
pas à l'aise avec le numérique et vous
le dites fort justement il y a un quart
des personnes de 60 à 64 ans qui ne
pratiquent pas l'informatique mais parmi
les jeunes dont on pourrait penser
compte tenu de ce qu'ils sont très
usagés des réseaux sociaux ils se sont
tirés davantage à l'aise avec le
numérique et bien il n'en est rien on
dit qu'il y a également un quart des 18
24 qui sont complètement démunis pour
mener à bien une démarche administrative
et donc ça ça rejoint parce que c'est
vraiment très étonnant c'est plutôt des
catégories on va dire de français en
difficulté les Français
évidemment
qui peut-être ont des problèmes
d'alphabétisation enfin vous voyez si on
essaye de détailler un peu qui sont ces
Français qui souffrent d'électronisme
mais il y a effectivement des personnes
handicapées par exemple qui n'ont pas
accès au moyen habituels il y a les
personnes détenues mais il y a aussi des
citoyens comme vous et moi qui pour
diverses raisons et bien non pas accès
au numérique ne se sont pas familiarisés
avec les outils numériques
on parle de gens qui ne savent pas s'en
servir
ça peut être un peu des deux aussi il y
a un certain nombre d'associations
justement qui travaillent à doté des
personnes défavorisées de matériel
informatique mais également les
accompagnent dans l'initiation aussi à
ces outils mais je crois que il y a
vraiment une grande partie de la
population qui est touchée et je suis
très heureuse que vous montriez quel est
l'ampleur du semaine et la modestie qui
sont mis des moyens qui sont mis en
place pour la combattre on en parlera
évidemment la question politique elle
viendra dans ce débat Muriel Barnet ou
là la poste c'est un maillage
territorial qui est évidemment très
important peut-être le dernier aussi
aussi serré dans notre pays ce maillage
peut-être une question ça représente
combien de bureau de poste et puis
surtout est-ce que ces bureaux de poste
ce sont aussi des lieux où on détecte
justement des Françaises des Français en
situation de d'électronique 17000 points
de contact 17000 points de contact et si
on le l'élarit même à tous les moments
de contact on est sur une diaspora qui
est encore beaucoup plus grande
puisqu'il évidemment il y a la question
des facteurs des points relais de nous
dont on dispose et il se trouve que non
seulement on a cette capillarité mais on
a aussi de fait et ça répond un petit
peu à la question que vous posiez une
proportion plus grande de personnes qui
viennent dans nos réseaux avec qui on va
à un moment ou un autre être en relation
et qui
de ce sujet là parce que nos missions
d'accessibilité bancaires parce que nos
missions d'aménagement du territoire
fait que par nature on va retrouver des
publics fragiles ou des personnes qui
ont besoin d'aide dans ces points de
contact vous voyez on est par exemple on
a 500 établissements qui sont françaises
publics qui sont proposés dans dans ces
maisons sont organisées pour travailler
avec ces personnes là est-ce que dit
Madame fiole est très important je pense
que on aurait tort de penser que la
chose va se résoudre avec le temps
oui et on accueille des jeunes mamans on
accueille des personnes qui ont une des
difficultés à écrire parce que se servir
d'un clavier
ça n'est pas simple du tout alors je
vais donner on va essayer de pas vous
noyer dans les chiffres mais je vais
vous en donner un autre qui vient du
baromètre du numérique 2022 il y en a un
qui est publié chaque année donc c'est
tout frais vient d'être publié 54% des
Français rencontrent des difficultés
face aux démarches en ligne et moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la tendance plus
16 points vous le voyez par rapport à
2020 je vais te les Dano évidemment
quand je vois ça je fais le lien avec la
crise covid est-ce que ça
accentué la fracture numérique cette
crise
est-ce que la crise covid a accentuer la
fracture numérique
peut-être que
il y a eu des situations encore plus
critiques mais je pense que
le sujet c'est de celui de voir dans un
monde qui en tout état de cause ce
numérique si on comment on le fait si on
le fait bien et qu'est-ce qu'on en
attend
il y a une vieille histoire que j'ai
envie de vous raconter une vie histoire
d'économiste vous savez les
plaisanteries l'économistes on va voir
nous sommes votre public
un grand économiste monsieur solo qui a
dit il y a maintenant c'était au 20e
siècle on voit porte partout des
ordinateurs sauf dans les gains de
productivité et la question était de
savoir pourquoi à l'époque il n'y avait
pas de gamme productivité et en fait on
a mis un moment à se rendre compte que
quand on faisait de l'informatique pour
faire des gains de productivité en
reproduisant la façon dont ça se faisait
dans le dans la vie manuelle j'ai envie
de dire à ce moment-là on loupait son
coup et je pense que l'un des grands
problèmes qui est pesé si
par exemple chez les jeunes vous dites
mais ils savent se servir des réseaux
sociaux et pas mais vous avez vu la
différence des applications des réseaux
sociaux et des applications qu'on nous
propose parfois sur certains
vous vous avez d'une part les interfaces
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes on est
d'accord
et donc je pense qu'il y a un vrai
problème de qualité un certain nombre de
services est-ce qu'il y a un problème de
formation aussi au numérique est-ce
qu'il y a encore besoin de formation
numérique
toujours bien sûr il y a toujours un
problème de formation mais la formation
n'est pas la réponse si vous dans une
numérique enfin on est beaucoup à avoir
eu des formations à tel ou tel logiciel
si vous en servez pas toutes les
semaines vous vous retenez pas donc
c'est pas souvent un problème de
formation c'est un problème d'ergonomie
c'est etc et puis vous aurez toujours
aussi comme
le disais madame la sénatrice ce sera
jamais 100% des gens non il faut être
dans une logique de complémentarité par
rapport à un certain nombre de choses
améliorer évidemment des interfaces il y
a certains services on se dit d'ailleurs
qui sont faits pour qu'on s'en sert pas
effectivement pour qu'on puisse pas
prendre de rendez-vous mais je veux pas
citer d'exemples et je crois qu'on a
tous vu mais en tout état de cause à un
moment donné il y a toujours des gens
qui ne pourront pas s'en servir pour
différentes raisons
les administrations publiques ont pas ou
l'État a pas la culture de ce qu'on
appelle l'expérience utilisateur qui est
la culture de numérique on a plutôt la
culture de faire tomber remplissez le
formulaire B12 quand vous allez faire
vos papiers d'entité mais vous
remplissez le formulaire B12 et il peut
être compliqué voilà et c'est cette
culture là elle est verticale alors que
la culture numérique elle est pas
verticale elle est horizontale et c'est
de la mise en réseau et de partager
l'expérience il faut bien voir de quoi
on parle on a la poste plus à peu près
une centaine de conseillers numériques
dans le cadre du plan de relance vous
savez qu'il y a 4000 conseillers
numériques qui ont été déployés avec la
NCT pour justement former au numérique
c'est bien mais alors 4000 conseillers à
côté 13 millions de de français on parle
pas de formation au sens de chose très
élaborée et très difficile on se
connecte ça peut être très élaboré
être capable de faire un login password
c'est
exactement français ça aide mais c'est
exactement comme apprendre à lire et ce
sont des choses qui sont très basiques
et qui ne sont pas sophistiquées et qui
pourtant nous on ne forme 20 000
personnes comme ça cette année c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental alors
on n'a pas encore donné la parole à
Jean-Marc et snoker avec nous en duplex
je voudrais bien en quelques mots que
vous nous présentiez de landes et puis
ensuite on va parler de de ruralité avec
vous comment cette cette fracture est-ce
que cette fracture numérique elle est
plus présente dans les territoires
ruraux ça semble une évidence est-ce que
c'est vrai
alors selon dans quelques mots c'est un
écosystème qui agrège 31 entités dans le
domaine de l'enseignement de la
formation et puis également dans le
domaine du développement économique et
de la vie sociale et culturelle
notre vocation c'est d'accompagner les
acteurs et futurs acteurs des
territoires ruraux et les dynamiques
territoriales qui permettent le
rééquilibrage entre ville et campagne
par rapport à ce qui a été dit peut-être
quelques précisions quand même on
évoquait tout à l'heure c'est 13
millions de Français parmi ces 13
millions de Français il faut avoir en
tête que 8 millions d'entre eux
n'utilisent pas internet faute
d'équipement ou faute de collection
évidemment les ruraux sont
particulièrement touchés parce que ce
sont des zones qui sont très mal
desservies en effet et puis par ailleurs
quand on regarde les populations qui
sont touchées par l'exclusion ou la
fracture numérique ce sont plutôt on va
le dire comme ça plutôt des personnes
âgées plutôt des personnes qui sont
moins diplômées plutôt des personnes
personne avec des moyens économiques
relativement limitées
quand on touche le RSA c'est 300 euros
par mois un équipement informatique
c'est 6 700 euros pour ce qui est un
ordinateur et finalement c'est critères
là sont des critères pour retrouver plus
de manière un peu plus évidente dans les
territoires ruraux que dans les
territoires urbains le niveau de vie en
ruralité et moins élevé dans les
territoires autant donc on voit bien
qu'en effet il se joue quelque chose de
d'un peu particulier ici et j'ai envie
de dire que
la ruralité aurait pu quelque part
s'appuyer sur le numérique pour être
relié aux autres territoires son
territoire aujourd'hui qui sont qui sont
dédiés pour plusieurs raisons mais enfin
notamment parce qu'il y a plus de moyens
de transport et de communication qui
permet d'aller de la ruralité vers les
grands centres
urbains donc là il y avait quelque chose
d'important qui se jouait
malheureusement aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que c'est ces
territoires ruraux sont laissés un petit
peu au banc même si j'entends bien qu'il
y a quelques quelques actions qui sont
conduites mais vous l'avez même
vous-même souligné 4000 conseillers
numériques à côté de ce chiffre de 13
millions de Français qui n'utilisent pas
internet c'est quand même très
conséquent c'est aussi très conséquent
par rapport aux 35000 communes
aujourd'hui en France alors je vous
donnerai la parole évidemment plusieurs
fois dans ces bases mais je reviens sur
cette progression des Français qui
disent le baromètre la nuit numérique
rencontrer des difficultés cette
proposition de 16 points en deux ans
comment vous voulez expliquer je j'ai
pas forcément la
bonne réponse moi je pense pour répondre
à votre question sur la crise à telle
accentuer les choses je pense que la
crise a accentuer l'usage du numérique
oui parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui se sont équipées
donc c'est devenu pas seulement un sujet
de service public mais un sujet de la
vie de tous les jours prendre un
rendez-vous
médical par
du relevé de notes du carnet
correspondance qui a disparu sous sa
forme papier qui est sous une forme
numérique et donc du coup je parle
d'entreprise les commerçants qui étaient
pas équipés ils ont bien vu qu'il
fallait
de la vie de tous les jours et donc le
le fait que y compris pour la vie de
tous les jours en soi soit pas équipé
soit pas relié soit pas en capacité de
l'utiliser de fait créer à nouveau une
difficulté et on le voit nous très bien
dans les personnes que l'on accueille il
y a des choses qui relèvent d'action
toute simple comme consulter un compte
utilisez un automate et si vous savez le
faire pour dans un bureau de poste vous
savez le faire
quand vous faites votre rendez-vous chez
un médecin donc je crois que c'est ça
qui l'accentue c'est le besoin lui-même
la pratique elle-même est plus fréquente
dans la vie de tous les jours
là de 4000 conseillers numériques bon
c'est c'est bien mais c'est évidemment
insuffisant il en faudrait combien
à la mesure du problème et effectivement
on aurait besoin d'une politique
publique d'inclusion numérique qui se
développe globalement parce qu'on ne
peut pas penser que les conseillers
numériques soient suffisants comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure il faut déjà
détecter le problème il y a des
personnes qui ne se rendent jamais dans
des lieux publics et justement moi je
défends l'idée que les facteurs peuvent
jouer un rôle dans cette détection parce
que les facteurs sont présents partout
en France ils sont présents également
dans des zones géographiques éloignées
et ils peuvent au moins nous permettre
de détecter les problèmes d'accord
mais ce n'est pas suffisant bien
évidemment moi je défends également la
position de la Défenseur des droits qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut absolument
maintenir un accès aux services publics
physiques ou téléphonique car ce sont au
service public à s'adapter aux besoins
des citoyens et non l'inverse
téléphoniques tout à l'heure et puis on
évidemment on évoquera aussi la question
du timbre rouge qui va parce que c'est
quand même aussi assez enfin pas
seulement symbolique mais je voudrais
d'abord qu'on fasse un focus tout de
suite à un gros plan dans cette dans ce
débat sur ce qu'on appelle les zones
blanches et ces Mathias Arès qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite
Mathias vous nous rappelez c'est quoi
c'est des zones peu denses alors quand
on fait le lien entre fracture numérique
et zone blanche ça donne quoi alors il
est difficile d'avoir des données
précises concernant les zones blanches
en revanche il y en a sur ces fameuses
zones peu dense qui sont souvent des
zones blanches selon les derniers
chiffres de l'arcel autorité de
régulation des communications
électroniques elles concernerait pas
moins de 18% de la population française
et près de 63% du territoire
métropolitain c'est ce sur votre écran
en bleu va se problème donc pour le tout
numérique mais des zones qui sont
aujourd'hui concernées par un plan de
déploiement prioritaire je suis très
surpris par cette carte pourquoi on en
est toujours à ce niveau et bien en
réalité il y a deux batailles qui sont
menées de front celles de la couverture
mobile avec des antennes et celles des
réseaux fixes par câble que représente
la fibre optique et nous vivons
actuellement un changement d'air on
passe du réseau cuivre au réseau fibre
optique pour la partie fixe pour le
mobile l'installation d'antenne est
onéreuse pour parfois peu d'habitants un
argument technique donc pour Patrick
chas sénateur LR de l'un et président du
groupe numérique au micro de Gaspard
flamand
la difficulté c'est c'est quand même
l'aspect technique c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut effectivement déployer des pylônes
il faut déployer des réseaux pour
recouvrir l'ensemble du territoire et
de façon assez logique plus le temps
avant et plus il est compliqué de
pouvoir donc couvrir les derniers
clients ou les derniers
usagers parce que évidemment donc les
opérateurs on peut le comprendre ont
d'abord donc fait des investissements là
où il y avait beaucoup de densité et
aujourd'hui on finit sur les la faible
densité donc il faut beaucoup d'antennes
pour peu de bénéficiaires à quel horizon
devrait y voir un peu plus clair Mathias
alors cet horizon est fixé par des
objectifs donnés par le gouvernement
comme dans le cadre du New Deal mobile
signé entre l'exécutif et les opérateurs
et pour le sénateur LR c'est Horizon a
bien une date
en 2030
la situation devrait être effectivement
que tout à chacun sur sa zone
d'habitation et à la fois donc une
connexion fibre optique très haut débit
quelques exceptions près mais qui auront
des solutions de substitution et une
couverture mobile alors en attendant
pour les personnes concernées il va
falloir s'accommoder avec un mix partage
de connexion sur les ordinateurs pour
ceux qui auraient du réseau mobile ou
appel Wi-Fi pour ceux qui auraient la
fibre mais pas de couverture
effectivement merci beaucoup
Mathias Jean-Marc Esnault il faut quand
même expliquer ce que ça change quand la
fibre arrive quelque part c'est quoi
c'est toute la tractivité d'un village
ou d'une zone qui est qui change même
dans la capacité à faire revenir des
habitants par exemple on peut dire ça
évidemment et
vous vous imaginez bien qu'une
entreprise qui veut s'installer demain
l'un des éléments ou l'un des critères
essentiels une condition pour qu'elle
s'installe c'est qu'elle ait accès au
numérique très difficile aujourd'hui de
conduire une activité économique si on
n'a pas accès au numérique donc de fait
si un territoire n'est pas desservi les
entreprises ne vont pas s'installer si
l'entreprise les entreprises ne
s'installe pas c'est une vie économique
qui n'existe pas donc des populations
qui ne viennent pas s'installer dans les
territoires ruraux ce qui est une vraie
problématique et ce qui est d'ailleurs
un peu paradoxal aujourd'hui c'est que
les enquêtes d'opinion nous montre que
les ménages de plus de 30 ans avec
enfants tout son envie d'aller plutôt au
vert plutôt en zone périurbaine dans les
zones avec un jardin une maison
individuelle et sauf qu'aujourd'hui il y
a un franc il y a des Francs et l'un de
ces francs là c'est c'est le numérique
peut-être une petite précision aussi
parce qu'il y a quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas évoqué ce soir mais en 2016 l'ONU a
reconnu l'accès sur Internet comme un
droit fondamental donc c'est à dire que
une partie de notre population en France
ne bénéficient pas des des droits
fondamentaux si on s'en tient à cette à
cette à ce que ce que dit l'oignon en
2016 vous avez aussi évoqué je me
permets de réagir là-dessus sur
les l'horizons 2030 moi je me souviens
d'un Premier ministre en 2015 qui disait
en 2016 tout territoire sera couvert je
souviens d'un ministre de l'Agriculture
qui en 2018 disait dans trois ans tout
le territoire français sera couvert on
est en 2023 les zones blanches existent
encore et votre carte était le
le prénom de la République quand il
parle de dépenses il dit non c'est des
investissements là c'est pour le coup
c'est de l'investissement qui est qu'on
peut rentabiliser assez rapidement quand
même même pour des zones très peu denses
et c'est ça la question je vous trouve
tous très très pessimiste sur la réalité
il se trouve qu'on vient de finir un
rapport à France stratégie je faisais
partie du conseil scientifique sur le
déploiement de la fibre qui a été
extrêmement rapide et qui atteint les
objectifs qui étaient fixés
qu'effectivement enfin avoir ou de la
fibre ou du mobile par rapport aux
objectifs de l'ONU je pense qu'ils sont
atteints donc il y a encore des tas de
progrès à faire mais franchement sur le
déploiement de la fibre il y a quand
même eu des résultats en rapport cette
avec les engagements qui étaient tenus
et puis il y en a d'autres pour se
prolonger et sur le mobile enfin le plan
4G il y a des améliorations mais très
franchement
on peut pas dire un qui est pas eu
d'investissement et deux qui est pas eu
des améliorations de couverture c'est
assez sensible tout n'est pas parfait il
y a encore des problèmes mais mais mais
de gros investissements ont été faits
avec plutôt des résultats les
difficultés étant plutôt on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler aujourd'hui sur
toute une série d'endroits la qualité de
la pose de la fibre n'a pas été ce
qu'elle aurait dû être et donc que vous
avez des sacs de nouilles qui sont
constituées
[Musique]
certains d'entre nous ont déjà été
amenés à voir à quel point quand on
mettait des connexions par exemple
en zone rurale du l'occasion de le voir
c'était pas très très bien fait les
fibres étaient déposées et il y a un
grand plan en ce moment qui est en train
de se s'organiser pour que les
opérateurs revois leur copie de ce
côté-là mais sinon je vous trouve plutôt
pessimiste mais je redonne la parole à
Jean-Marc esnolasu parce que tout à
l'heure vous disiez quoi c'est sur les
13 millions il y en a il y a 8 millions
de Français c'est faute
d'équipement ou faute de connexion
ou c'est parce que effectivement le le
la fibre ou les deux d'accord bon les
deux donc
concernant le le la question de
l'investissement il est en effet
aujourd'hui
conséquent on ne peut pas nier
maintenant tout dépend où on place le
curseur je pense que là les enjeux sont
sont un peu essentiels je reviens vers
vous dans un instant je voulais juste je
vous redonner à la pour l'instant faute
mais je voudrais juste avoir une
précision sur le site de union c'est
qu'on soit bien précis c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup de français quand même je
ne crois pas vous n'y allez qui chez eux
n'ont pas la possibilité après il y a la
qualité du matériel etc mais je ne crois
pas d'accord que 8 millions de Français
loin s'en fout n'est pas la possibilité
technique d'avoir la connexion
que nous pose notamment on va dire les
plus de 65 ans lorsque on vient sur
cette détection et sur la proposition de
faire de cette formation au numérique à
quoi bon
la première question qu'on nous pose
c'est à quoi bon pourquoi faire et à
quoi est-ce que ça me servirait donc de
le faire donc et c'est pas perçu comme
un moyen de d'être activité ou de rompre
l'isolement ou de comment je vais faire
et c'est bien ça n'est pas pour moi et
c'est justement ça que les les idées de
Madame filleul sont intéressantes parce
que il y a beaucoup de ce qu'on va
appeler sovskill c'est à dire de
capacité humaine à comprendre ce que
sont les freins de comportemental à
franchir ses freins pour amener ces
personnes isolées et qui n'ont pas les
équipements mais aussi parce qu'elles
n'en voit pas l'intérêt
à comprendre que ça pourrait leur servir
à quelque chose on a on a construit une
offre comme ça dans l'univers postal qui
s'appelle ardoise qui fait ça en fait
qui qui sert exactement à ce dont ont
besoin des seniors plus plus pour
dialoguer avec leurs petits-enfants etc
par exemple
quand on voit le niveau effectivement de
couverture mobile avec des téléphones le
problème c'est qu'avec un smartphone
c'est quand même très très difficile de
remplir les formulaires de Pôle emploi
de cas après vous avez ici le seul accès
c'est le smartphone effectivement que ça
c'est souvent le cas il faut bien avoir
en tête que le premier matériel
informatique si je peux en tête c'est
effectivement un smartphone et les
jeunes dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
c'est avec ça maintenant faire un scan
de façon facile pour communiquer etc
après on rentre si vous voulez dans dans
les
usages et là c'est une autre histoire
Mathieu vouliez profiter de ce débat
pour revenir sur un coup de gueule du
président oui alors nous sommes le 5
janvier c'est jour de galette à l'Élysée
et les boulangers se font un sang
d'encre face à la flambée de leur
facture d'électricité et il se plaignent
notamment des dispositifs
d'accompagnement mise en place par le
gouvernement qu'il juge insuffisant
quand tout d'un coup ils vont trouver un
soutien inat de la part du chef de
l'État regardez
on m'avait donné un numéro vert mais il
se trouve que j'ai eu un bon réflexe
j'ai testé le numéro vert qu'on m'a
donné avant
ça marche pas donc on va s'organiser
d'ici lundi non mais donc
et moi j'en ai ras-le-bol des numéros
verts dans tous les sens
arrow sur les numéros donc ça manque pas
de sel quand même de la part d'un
exécutif qui en a usé et même abusé
diront certains ça a beaucoup été relevé
mais le président de son explication
persiste et signe et il dit on va donner
un numéro par département parce qu'il
faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un au bout du
fil qui répondent à la fois avec
humanité expertise et qui ne soit pas un
site internet qui renvoie à des tableaux
beaucoup de nos artisans ont toute chose
à faire que vous allez chercher dans les
sites Internet des circulaires
absolument éligibles ou des tableaux
incompréhensibles et il ajoute le même
parce qu'il l'a fait j'ai fait
l'exercice c'est impossible alors
comment expliquer cette colère du chef
de l'État alors il y a une part de
communication gouvernementale bien sûr
avec des raisons politiques ça fait
quand même cinq ans qu'on reproche à ce
pouvoir d'être trop parisien trop techno
trop déconnecté des préoccupations des
Français et c'est une critique qui finit
inquiéter l'exécutif et qui finit par
agacer aussi l'exécutif Emmanuel Macron
a mis les pieds dans le plat lors du
dernier conseil des ministres il faut se
mettre à la place des gens a-t-il
inviter les membres du gouvernement et
rester proche des préoccupations des
Français pas on peut juger ou non qu'il
le met en pratique mais en tout cas il y
a quand même cette volonté de pas être
déconnecté et puis et une autre raison
politique mais politique au pratique
j'ai envie de dire c'est que la startup
nation ça c'est limite à quoi bon ce
fixer comme objectif d'atteindre d'avoir
100 licornes françaises si on n'est pas
fichu de faire des sites Internet qui
tiennent la route et surtout de les
rendre accessibles et de fait pour
revenir à notre sujet c'est un des
aspects de la fracture numérique de trop
nombreux Français se sentent coupés de
tout et n'osent plus faire de démarches
parce qu'il n'y arrive pas on est déjà
dans un pays où on rappelle qu'un taux
de non recours très élevé pour certaines
aides sociales parce que c'est compliqué
parce qu'on a honte de les demander tout
simplement parce qu'on sait pas quoi
faire alors quand en plus ça se passe
sur Internet et qu'on peut pas y aller
ça en rajoute actuellement il y a 15%
des Français qui ne disposent pas de de
connexion internet à domicile si j'ai
bien compris selon une étude en tout cas
mené par 60 millions de consommateurs
pour Défenseur des droits et il y en a
28% qui se disent pas capable
d'effectuer une démarche administrative
en ligne alors pire si on rajoute le
pire du pire c'est que certains
organismes pour certains organismes même
les standards téléphoniques sont aux
abonnés absents 60 millions de
consommateurs à mener cette enquête ils
ont passé près un peu plus de 1500 coups
de fil notamment auprès de l'assurance
maladie de la caisse de l'oscope action
familiale de la caisse des retraites ou
encore de Pôle emploi et alors là tenez
vous bien à votre chaise 72% de taux de
coût de fil inabouti à l'Assurance
Maladie 54% à la CAF 28% la Caisse
d'assurance retraite et 16% à Pôle
emploi c'est évidemment moins que à
l'assurance maladie mais ça reste quand
même beaucoup trop pour des gens voilà
qui ne sait plus qui ne savent plus vers
qui se tourner alors ça m'a moins
surpris pour être honnête Mathieu que
les 13 millions parce que bon voilà ça
m'est arrivé d'appeler l'assurance
maladie et de jamais avoir personne
modifié mais comment ça s'explique ça
jouer le Toledano c'est quoi ça il y a
plus de personnel c'est des fautes
d'organisation c'est une volonté aucune
volonté alors je sais pas qui veut
répondre une volonté politique cette
numérisation à marche forcée des
services publics c'est une volonté du
gouvernement affichée maintenant depuis
longtemps c'est un choix on l'avait vu
mais
services publics c'est moi je dis très
bien ils sont pas condamnés à être un
gars les services publics mais la
question c'est il faut avoir les deux en
même temps je vais vous faire d'abord le
raisonnement un peu techno et puis après
on va passer à autre chose
vous avez un service numérique et qu'à
côté vous avez un numéro de téléphone
qui est aussi facilement accessible
notre paresse normale ou nos habitudes
nos habitudes mais un peu paresseuse
éventuellement enfin un quart d'heure
nous de la paresse pour faire que c'est
plus agréable et plus simple on va
prendre donc on va téléphoner pour
pousser les gens à utiliser le numérique
on met pas facilement un numéro de
téléphone ça c'est le la première
explication un peu rationnelle si on
entend les quatre saisons de Vivaldi en
boucle trois quart d'heure
et là
c'est partout
je ne dirais pas ma voisine que c'est
pareil ailleurs mais c'est partout c'est
vous savez ce truc vous appelez si vous
êtes machin appuyez sur un si vous êtes
et vous parce que vous avez un numéro de
téléphone maintenant il y a tout le
monde a des numéros de téléphone mais au
milieu vous avez des disques qui vous
orientent et surtout ne pas vous
orienter vers une vraie personne et
essayer là encore sur le téléphone de
vous traiter encore en automatiques et
je pense que mais alors il y a pas mal
de il y a pas mal de réponses peuvent
être traitées par un robot un chatbot
quoi ça c'est vrai il y en a pas mal il
y en a pas mal mais il faut quand même
de l'humain voilà et le problème c'est
d'organiser la complémentarité c'est de
considérer que tout ne rentre pas dans
une boîte et que il faut pas qu'on vous
demande avant d'avoir un humain 15
chiffres qui permettront de vérifier que
c'est bien vous que c'est pas quelqu'un
d'autre et etc Muriel Barnet ou votre
avis là-dessus parce que c'est on peut
aussi dire c'est une façon de de ne plus
donner aux salariés ou aux agents de la
Poste les tâches les moins intéressantes
je dis pas que répondre au téléphone
c'est pas intéressant mais oui si on
confie un robot les réponses les plus
évidentes ça permet à l'humain d'être là
quand il y en a vraiment besoin et ça
c'est un peu la logique alors d'avoir
vous avez dit quelque chose que si je
peux me permettre que je trouve très
importantes qui est que il y a pas de
raison que parce que c'est du service
public ou qu'il soit il devrait être un
gars et ne pas adopter ce qui est le
meilleur des technologies pour pouvoir
être produit je pense que les pages
d'accueil on parlait d'interface au
niveau quoi on est très content de
pouvoir faire une démarche
administrative en ligne il y a 4 heures
du matin si on évite la faire à 4h du
matin plutôt que poser une demi-journée
de congé pour aller chercher un document
qu'on aurait trouvé voilà donc c'est
très important je pense que ce que vous
dites encore une fois si je peux me le
permettre est très important c'est très
important qu'on soit dans l'idée que
c'est fondamental que nos services
publics soient mod quel qu'il soit et
bien sûr dans ce cas là c'est important
pour nous cette fois-ci en tant
qu'opérateur que l'humain soit au
service des problèmes les plus
compliqués parce qu'ils vont prendre du
temps et parce qu'ils vont devoir
dégager tout ce temps là aussi un peu de
logique économique
aussi partie bien sûr bien sûr parce que
ça fait partie de l'efficacité ces
services publics ils ont besoin d'être
modernes et ils ont besoin d'être
efficaces et dans l'efficacité il est
évident quelqu'un qui vient je parle
pour par exemple pour la Banque Postale
consultez un solde qu'il pourrait
totalement consulter depuis un
smartphone depuis un automate et qui
prend ce temps là du chargé de clientèle
qui en revanche à quelque chose qui ne
peut pas être automatisé qui va prendre
du temps pour la personne qui est
derrière c'est c'est quelque part gâchis
donc oui bien sûr et ça n'est rien ça
n'a rien de déshumanisant on est tout
aussi humain et tout aussi présent je
vous propose d'écouter sur ce thème là
la réaction de de Claire et Don la
Défenseur des droits la part de l'humain
dans le service public
et ce qui me frappe c'est qu'en fait on
demande à l'usager de s'adapter au
service public de faire toutes les
démarches d'avoir un ordinateur d'être
en capacité de remplir d'être connecté à
Internet de pas faire d'erreur quand il
le remplit autrement il n'arrive pas à
faire valoir ses droits alors qu'en fait
c'est au service public de s'adapter et
dans notre préconisations ce qu'on
demande c'est un maintien de l'accueil
physique téléphonique dans les services
publics pour que quand on rencontre une
difficulté on puisse aller voir un agent
de service public et résoudre son
problème résoudre son dossier alors le
défi il est pas si simple Martin fille
comment moderniser les services publics
sans les déshumaniser parce que c'est un
peu ça le débat qu'on est en train de
maintenir plusieurs canaux d'accès aux
services publics selon les besoins de la
personne pour résoudre en particulier je
rejoins ce qui a été dit les problèmes
complexes parce que vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure français vie ou également
on l'a vu les services téléphoniques ça
permet d'avoir des réponses assez
générales mais quand on a un problème un
peu compliqué particulier c'est vraiment
très important d'avoir la possibilité
d'un accès physique et d'une personne
extrêmement compétente et pointue sur
les sujets alors je voudrais qu'on parle
il nous reste quelques minutes de la
suppression du timbre rouge Muriel
Barnéo alors ça permettait une livraison
à 24 heures c'est remplacé par une
lettre numérique si j'ai bien compris
donc là on est un peu quand même au cœur
de notre débat c'est-à-dire pour ceux
qui souffrent de cette fracture
numérique comment ils vont faire alors
peut-être un peu perdu face à l'offre à
la nouvelle offre oui sans reprendre les
propos de Joël quelques chiffres quand
même qui explique 15 45 et 3
il y a 15 ans
les Français
utilisaient à peu près 45 lettres dites
timbre rouge par an parfois
aujourd'hui 3
3 ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'utilisation de ce fameux lettre timbre
rouge est une utilisation qui est une
initiation extrêmement rare et peu
importe ça veut dire que ça veut dire
que c'est c'est plus une préoccupation
bah ça dépasse ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous avez besoin de
24 heures vous avez d'autres solutions
et notamment des sujets
et bien sûr que nous avons tous nos
autres dispositifs tous nos services la
lettre verte qui est en deux en deux
jours donc qu'est-ce qui oui qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en fait aujourd'hui ça
consistait à dire ce produit là se
produit qui aujourd'hui nécessite des
avions
nécessitent des camions
pour trois en moyenne par an et parfois
y est est-ce qu'il n'y a pas plus
efficace à la fois d'un point de vue
écologique et efficace d'un point de vue
économique donc parmi les éléments
d'efficacité il y a toutes nos autres
solutions donc vraiment que tout le
monde nous entendent nous continuons à
transporter du courrier et assurer le
service du courrier partout en France en
tout cas du territoire alors plus
lentement qu'avant pas tout à fait à
plus un plan 15 ans mais pas tout à fait
puisqu'en fait parmi les éléments qui
sont les éléments de modernité ce que
l'on propose c'est si vous voulez que ce
courrier soit remis sous une forme
papier dans ce cas-là nous nous
l'imprimons au plus près de son
destinataire pour qu'il soit
un mail vous recevez une lettre alors
justement pour qu'une personne si vous
avez besoin mais le raisonnement est
tout simple si la personne qui aimait le
courrier a besoin d'envoyer un courrier
à une personne qui voit va recevoir un
courrier matériel on a une solution on a
une solution qui est nous l'imprimons
nous l'imprimons en bout de chaîne je
vois bien la logique effectivement son
camion non mais je vois bien la logique
mais ça rejoint quand même notre débat
je vais te donner c'est pas très sérieux
pourquoi c'est pas très sérieux d'abord
je reprends
l'histoire
la Poste a inventé le timbre vert il y a
une dizaine d'années parce que justement
il y avait des avions et que etc etc
donc elle a organisé le passage du
timbre rouge au timbre vert par ailleurs
il y a eu la diminution mais il y a eu
vraiment eu c'était d'ailleurs assez
difficile de trouver des timbres rouges
on trouvait plus facilement des timbre
vert et puis là non seulement on
supprime le rouge mais on supprime aussi
le vert puisqu'on passe agis plus 3 J +
3 ça veut dire J+3 quand votre mais pas
du tout quand vous mettez le LED dans
votre boîte parce que vous avez bien vu
vous vos boîtes aux lettres maintenant
elles sont relevées à 9 heures du matin
donc
vraiment on a une
ralentissement qui est pas du tout juste
pour les avions parce que à ce moment là
si vraiment c'est un problème d'économie
d'énergie il faut arrêter de faire du
courrier complètement donc s'il y a un
service et qui a un besoin
à ce moment-là moi je crois que ce qui
resterait c'est qu'on va accélérer la
chute du courrier et que du coup c'est
aussi très mauvais pour le colis et que
donc vous avez raison de faire
ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'on
comprend bien que la poste soit amenée à
revoir sa stratégie mais de là à tomber
dans Kafka je trouve qu'il y a sans
doute des protocoles ou des procédures à
trouver qui soit plus adapté aux besoins
de la population et je voudrais aussi
insister sur le fait que malheureusement
derrière il se cache sans doute la
diminution des tournées des facteurs
dans les zones rurales même si la poste
sans défend c'est ce qu'il y a en
perspective et là je voudrais dire que
ça crée vraiment beaucoup de colère
beaucoup d'inquiétudes parce que c'est
une conception du service public qui est
attaquée qui est en berne en quelque
sorte
pour rassurer tout le monde et vous au
premier chef madame fiole nous
n'organisons pas des diminutions de
volume avec l'idée de derrière des
optimiser ou éviter le passage du
facteur le facteur il continue à passer
par tout tous les jours et il s'arrête
chaque fois qu'il a quelque chose à
remettre que ce soit un courrier que ce
soit un colis que ce soit un service à
rendre il l'a toujours fait et il le
fera toujours bien évidemment que nous
nous adaptons aux évolutions de volume
ça c'est une évidence sinon on pourrait
nous le reprocher aux évolutions d'usage
qui sont des évolutions d'usage Joël et
dans ces évolutions d'usage aujourd'hui
il y a des solutions alternatives à ce
qui a été quelque chose emblématique
mais c'est ça aussi un service public
qui se modernise et qui vit et qui vont
on a entendu les arguments des uns les
autres merci beaucoup merci à tous les
cinquième assises de assise de la
cohésion numérique et territoriale
s'ouvrent donc demain Joël toile à votre
livre Gaffard reprenant le pouvoir c'est
aux édition DJ Jacob et Jean-Marc
Esnault je cite exact également le vôtre
pardon bienvenue dans la nouvelle
ruralité aux éditions
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité votre prochain rendez-vous
politique sur notre antenne Christian
Cambon prison LR de la commission des
affaires étrangères de défense et des
forces armées du Sénat invité Lauriane
mansini il sera 8 heures du matin belle
soirée
[Musique]